[Musique]
une chambre un bureau et un salon de
musique le musée de la toile de Jouy
vient d'inaugurer trois nouvelles pièces
d'évocation historiques le but plonger
au cœur de la production de la
manufacture d'Oberkampf au 18e siècle on
y découvre toute la variété des types de
motifs qui étaient produits à jouer en
Josas les petites saunettes les toiles à
personnages ou ou des
motifs floraux vraiment et puis comment
est-ce qu'on les utilisait sur des
rideaux sur des murs sur des silhouettes
on était dans des vitrines enfin un
petit peu poussiéreuses il faut quand
même le reconnaître pas très vivante
lieu de mémoire voilà mais au-delà de ça
aujourd'hui les musées se doivent d'être
interactifs ou les gens peuvent s'amuser
s'exprimer et donc là c'est une
transformation totale là où il y avait
des vitrines bien sous leur cloche en
verre là aujourd'hui on a un lieu de vie
un lieu de vie où les visiteurs peuvent
dorénavant créer leur propre toile de
Jouy grâce à un écran tactile mis à
disposition dans le salon de musique la
toile de Jouy c'est un tissu qui se vit
on vit avec on le porte on le on en
parle son intérieur et aujourd'hui
évidemment de moins en moins de gens
l'utilisent et ont trouvé très important
notamment pour les jeunes générations de
leur montrer comment on vivait en toile
de jouer au XVIIIe et comment aussi on
pouvait grâce à ce dispositif numérique
de projection de motifs découvrir la
richesse de ces motifs de toiles de
jouer coût total des travaux 600 000
euros avec une contribution du
département et de la région de France
d'environ 50%. c'est unique la toile de
juillet est un objet unique il n'y a pas
d'équivalent il y a pas d'équivalent en
France et la commune de Jouy-en-Josas
souhaite aller encore plus loin avec un
projet développer une futur cité de la
toile une cité de la toile qui sera à la
fois amusée mais un musée qui soit un
lieu de vie un lieu d'expression qui
soit pas un simple lieu de conservation
de mémoire
et qui sera également à centre de
formation au métier textile et un lieu
de création textile innovant un projet
pour honorer la mémoire dobercance
l'ouvrit allemand est venu fonder sa
manufacture en France à l'âge de 22 ans
et à bouleverser le monde du textile un
entrepreneur d'avant-garde